Фермерці Ґабріеле Меріксманн потрібно багато соломи для її свиней.
Адже у своєму свинарнику вона керується інтересами тварин,
не сприймаючи їх лише як худобу для забою.
Меріксманн поводиться зі свиньми як з гідними поваги живими істотами.
Їхній добробут для неї - на першому місці.
Фермерка щодня публікує Сторіз у Фейсбук зі своєї так званої "активної" стайні.
Вона каже: споживачам це подобається.
Свиней тут не замикають у тісному загоні, як у звичайних свинарниках.
Вони можуть вільно пересуватися між кількома стайнями.
Як наслідок тварини не набирають вагу так швидко,
вирощування триває довше і коштує дорожче.
Але мета фермерки - утримувати тварин належним чином.
І двом тисячам її свиней це явно до вподоби.
Збільшивши простір удвічі, ми фактично створили такий собі світ, в якому свиням є чим займатися.
Вдвічі більше місця коштує більше грошей.
Зате тварини можуть обирати: ми хочемо вийти на вулицю,
чи ми хочемо піти у солом'яний куточок, чи ми хочемо зайти в душову, чи до зони відпочинку.
Вони можутьцілий день обирати, куди піти.
Навколо свинарника паркан і ворота.
Меріксманн хоче захистити своїх домашніх свиней від африканської чуми,
яку часто розносять дикі кабани.
За кілька кілометрів звідси - стайня Йорна Елерса.
Він захищає своїх дві тисячі свиней гігієнічним шлюзом на вході.
Його тварини живуть, як і більшість свиней у Німеччині, у простій звичайній стайні.
Мало свободи пересування, і так 24 години на добу.
Захисники прав тварин різко критикують цю форму господарства.
Але Елерс більше переймається іншим. З моменту спалаху африканської чуми
його тварини подешевшали приблизно на 20 центів за кілограм.
Кожен може порахувати, якщо свинар у регіоні в середньому утримує близько 700-800 особин,
то це раптова втрата 15-20 тисяч євро від вартості свиней у сараї.
Ціна падає, оскільки азійські країни призупинили імпорт німецької свинини,
боячись африканської чуми.
Йорн Елерс та експерт з продажів Альберт Гортманн-Шольтен занепокоєні.
Німецькі споживачі їдять лише найкращі шматки свинини,
тож досі місцеві фермери мали зиск завдяки культурі харчування в Азії.
Ринки надзвичайно добре доповнювали один одного.
Німці в основному їдять смажену свинину на кшталт шніцелів та відбивних,
а азіати віддають перевагу жиру і салу, хрящам, вухам, ніжкам, хвостам -
тому, що в нас не дуже користується попитом.
І тут, у Європі, буде надзвичайно складно завоювати
або відкрити ринки збуту для цих частин
Ґабріеле Меріксманн розробила іншу маркетингову стратегію для свиней з її  "активної" стайні.
В умовах кризи вона себе виправдала.
Фермерка тісно співпрацює з Сарою Дем, яка керує невеликим м'ясокомбінатом.
Тут щотижня переробляють 80 свиней з ферми Меріксманн.
Це вимагає більше часу, ніж на великих підприємствах.
Адже тут прагнуть збувати усі частини свині, а не лише філе.
Це досягається, зокрема, завдяки великій кількості різноманітних рецептів ковбас.
Сара Дем продає м’ясо та ковбасні вироби у регіонах Німеччини,
тож не залежить від далеких експортних ринків.
Однак і в Німеччині ринок теж має свої межі.
Ми можемо дуже добре збувати голови та черево.
Для цього ми здіснюємо продажі у формі бекону, м'яса голови, зельцу.
Це все ще можливо. Але зі збільшенням обсягів ми досягнемо своїх меж.
А щодо свинячих ніжок, хвостів та вух,
чесно визнаю, що їх ми вже й зараз не можемо позбутися.
Але це лише незначний недолік.
Натомість Ґабріеле Меріксманн, на відміну від традиційних фермерів,
які залежать від азійських ринків, не треба турбуватися про свої продажі.
І ціна на м'ясо її свиней також залишається стабільною.
З точки зору ефективності ми перебуваємо десь між звичайним фермерством та біо.
Я можу сказати, що інтерес фермерів до нашої системи дуже великий.
Взагалі кожна з концепційгідного утримання тварин у Німеччині
нині користується шаленим попитом.
Більшого добробуту для тварин прагнуть не лише фермери, а й чимало роздрібних торговців.
Дешеві м’ясні продукти вже повністю зникли з цього супермаркету.
На прилавку є лише свинина з "активних" стаєнь, приміром, від Меріксманн.
Це на 30 відсотків дорожче звичайної свинини,
тож є певний економічний ризик для супермаркетів.
Однак і їм йдеться не лише про гроші.
Звичайно, ми втратили деяких споживачів, які тепер купують дешеве м'ясо
зі звичайних господарств в інших магазинах,
але ми помітили, що отримали й багато нових клієнтів,
деякі з яких навмисно приїжджають здалеку.
Щорічно в Німеччині забивають близько 55 мільйонів свиней.
Наразі лише дуже мало з них походять із таких "активних" стаєнь.
Але Ґабріеле Меріксманн впевнена, що їх ставатиме дедалі більше.